Von Hongkong bis Indien, vom
südchinesische Meer und bis zu
den Senkaku-Inseln im Ostchinesischen Meer...
Der chinesische Riese steckt seine Claims ab und
demonstriert seinen Nachbarn seit Monaten,
dass sie es mit eine unerbittlichen wie
unersättlichen Supermacht zu tun haben.
Peking macht deutlich, wer von nun an
das Sagen und alle Fäden der Macht in der Hand
hat, ganz klar den Ton in dieser Region angibt.
Dabei hat China keine Sekunde lang gezögert,
praktisch alle seine Nachbarn vor den Kopf zu
stoßen. Allein in den letzten zwei Jahren
hatte China Zusammenstöße mit Malaysia,
den Philippinen, Vietnam, Südkorea, Brunei,
Japan und Hongkong. Mal ganz vom Coronavirus, dem
Handelskrieg mit den USA und den diplomatischen
Scharmützeln mit Australien zu schweigen.
Und natürlich bildet Taiwan dabei keine
Ausnahme. Ganz im Gegenteil! Die Beziehungen
zwischen der Volksrepublik China und Taiwan
durchlaufen eine der spannungsreichsten
Perioden der letzten Jahrzehnte.
In den letzten Monaten wurden wir Zeugen
wirtschaftlicher Drohgebärden, groß angelegter
Militärmanöver, aktiven politischen Drucks,
ja einer regelrechten Kampagne zum Ausschluss
Taiwans aus internationalen Institutionen
und auch der wiederholten Verletzung des
taiwanesischen Luftraums und seiner Gewässer durch
die "Volksbefreiungsarmee", wie die Streitkräfte
der Volksrepublik China formell genannt werden.
Nach der schamlosen Vereinnahmung
Hongkongs scheint nun also klar zu sein,
worauf Peking auch im Falle Taiwans zusteuert.
Und deswegen müssen wir die folgenden
Schlüsselfragen dringend beantworten:
Wie kann die Verteidigung Taiwans sichergestellt
werden? Wäre es überhaupt möglich, diese Insel
vor einer möglichen Invasion zu schützen?
Was geschieht im Augenblick in Taiwan?
Passt gut auf, denn von der
Beantwortung dieser Fragen
hängt nicht nur das Schicksal Taiwans
ab - sondern das der ganzen freien Welt,
die mehr und mehr dem Wohlgefallen und den
Expansionsgelüsten Pekings ausgeliefert ist.
(DER ROTE DRACHE)
Die Kommunistische Partei Chinas beansprucht
die volle Hoheit über das kleine, wohlhabende
und demokratische Taiwan und seine 24 Millionen
Einwohner. Wie wir Euch bereits in anderen Videos
erklärt haben, ist dies Pekings Politik seit der
Gründung der Inselrepublik im Jahre 1949.
In den letzten Jahrzehnten war Peking
jedoch der Ansicht, dass die wachsenden
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen Bindungen,
die seit der Öffnung der chinesischen Wirtschaft
zur Welt entstanden sind, die künftige friedliche
Integration Taiwans gemäß eines speziellen
Modells erleichtern würden - in Anlehnung
an die bis vor kurzem in Hongkong geltende
jahrelange Doktrin "Ein Land, zwei Systeme".
Damit haben sich die
Kommunisten jedoch verrechnet.
Freiheit, Demokratie und Offenheit gegenüber dem
Westen haben - surprise, surprise - zu
einer ganz anderen Stimmung geführt.
Heute identifizieren sich mindestens zwei
Drittel der Taiwanesen nicht mehr als Chinesen,
sondern einfach als Taiwanesen. Ebenso haben
mehr als 60% der Bevölkerung ein negatives
Bild von Festland-China, insbesondere natürlich
von dessen Regierung und politischem System.
Taiwan sieht sich immer weniger als
"chinesisch". Eine Position, welche seine
Präsidentin Tsai Ing-wen selbst teilt.
Die schlechte Nachricht ist natürlich,
dass China das seiner Ansicht nach legitime
Recht auf eine Wiedervereinigung Taiwans mit
dem Festland nie aufgegeben hat, und das
selbst wenn dies den Einsatz von Gewalt
bedeuten würde. Xi Jinping selbst hat diese
"Idee" klar und ganz offen verteidigt. Und
mehr noch: er hat eine wortwörtliche
"Deadline" für Taiwan festgesetzt:
das Jahr 2049 - den hundertsten Jahrestag
der Kommunistischen Revolution in China.
Was also einst als eine weit entfernte Möglichkeit
erschien, ist jetzt zu einer nicht mehr besonders
unwahrscheinlichen Bedrohung geworden.
Denn die Regierung Xi Jinping hat,
vielleicht um den wirtschaftlichen Abschwung,
den China in den letzten Jahren erlebt hat,
politisch zu kompensieren, eine derart
nationalistische Agenda in Gang gesetzt, wie
China sie seit Jahrzehnten nicht mehr erlebt hat.
China bekräftigt seine Gebietsansprüche und das
führt zu Konflikten in ganz Asien. CNN)
(China nimmt mehr Konflikte in der Welt auf
sich. Von den entlegenen Tälern des Himalaja
über kleine tropische Inseln bis hin zu den
angespannten westlichen Hauptstädten schürt ein
zunehmend durchsetzungsstärkeres China Konflikte
in der ganzen Welt wie nie zuvor, während sich die
Vereinigten Staaten zurückziehen. Bangkok Post)
Und jetzt, angesichts der Coronavirus-Krise,
könnte alles noch schlimmer kommen.
Sag selbst: gibt es einen besseren Weg,
um die Aufmerksamkeit des Volks von seinen
eigentlichen Problemen abzulenken, als
Konflikte anzuheizen, bei denen der
eigene Nationalstolz auf dem Spiel steht?
Was? Du willst, dass ich Dir dafür ein paar
konkrete Beispiele im Falle Chinas
nenne? Ok, das ist ein Kinderspiel!
Also, schau Dir mal das Südchinesische
Meer an! Ein Meer mit kleinen Inseln,
Riffen und Sandbänken, das auch für
den Welthandel von entscheidender
Bedeutung ist. Einige der verkehrsreichsten
Schifffahrtsrouten der Welt führen durch
dieses Meer, praktisch ein Drittel
des gesamten globalen Seehandels.
Und jetzt schau mal, wie die Dinge hier laufen!
Der chinesische Riese argumentiert, dass praktisch
das gesamte Meer zu China gehört - dass
es Teil seiner Hoheitsgewässer ist. Peking
hat keinerlei Skrupel gehabt, mindestens
fünf weitere Länder mit dieser Behauptung
vor den Kopf zu stoßen: die Philippinen,
Vietnam, Malaysia, Indonesien und Brunei.
Und Du glaubst mit nicht, wie unglaublich
unverschämt die nationalistischen
Kommunisten dabei vorgehen?
Dann hör Dir mal folgendes an:
Um seine Ansprüche im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes zu
"zementieren", baut Rot-China seit dem Jahr 2014
sogar künstliche Inseln auf Riffen und Sandbänken.
D.h. es schafft "chinesisches Territorium",
wo es zuvor gar nicht war. Stell Dir vor,
Russland würde in der Elbmündung eine Insel
aufschütten und dann die Schifffahrt durch
sein neues "Hoheitsgewässer" kontrollieren.
Und die neuen chinesischen Inseln sind nicht bloß
Sandhaufen. Ganz und gar nicht! Peking baut sie
zu regelrechten Festungen aus. Mit Flugpisten,
Raketenabschussbasen und Luftabwehrsystemen. Und
dass die internationale Gemeinschaft diese freche
und aggressive Expansion verurteilt, juckt die
roten Machthaber natürlich nicht die Bohne.
Etwas weiter nördlich, im Ostchinesischen Meer,
gehen sie auf vollen Konfrontationskurs
mit Japan. Es geht um die Frage,
wem die Senkakus gehören sollen, eine
Kette von felsigen, unbewohnten Inseln.
Außerdem kam es im Sommer 2020 im Himalaja
zu einem Zusammenstoß chinesischer und
indischer Soldaten. Das ganze ging
nicht über ein Scharmützel hinaus,
aber wir sprechen von einem Scharmützel, das
20 indischen Soldaten das Leben kostete und
zur Besetzung von etwa 40 km2 durch China führte.
Tja... und dann wäre da noch Hongkong... Was kann
man darüber eigentlich noch sagen? China hat dort
mit Gewelt ein neues "Sicherheitsgesetz" verhängen
lassen, das im Grunde der Meinungsfreiheit
und politischen Teilhabe der Bevölkerung einer
der freiheitsliebendsten Metropolen der Welt
nach fast 70 Jahren ein jähes Ende bereitet.
Und eines, meine lieben Zuschauer,
müssen wir uns vergegenwärtigen:
was in Hongkong geschehen ist, entspricht
in etwa dem, was es bedeutet hätte,
wenn Truppen des Warschauer Paktes im
Kalten Krieg West-Berlin besetzt hätten.
China hat internationale Abkommen, die
lokale Regierung und die bürgerlichen
Freiheiten der Bevölkerung Hongkongs, ohne
mit der Wimper zu zucken, übergangen.
Hinzu kommen der Handelskrieg mit den
Vereinigten Staaten, die Verhängung von
Strafzöllen gegen Australien, die
Verfolgung lokaler Minderheiten,
wie die Uiguren, und natürlich
das Mobbing gegen gegen Taiwan.
Und im Jahr 2020 zog China die Schlinge um den
Hals des Inselstaates so fest zu wie nie zuvor:
dazu gehörten die die größten
Luftwaffen- und Marinemanöver
seit langem in unmittelbarer und
demonstrativer Nähe zu Taiwan.
Selbst die offizielle chinesische Presse
bezeichnete diese unverhohlen als eine Übungen
zur Vorbereitung einer echten Invasions.
Darüber hinaus hat China nicht gezögert,
den taiwanesischen Luftraum wiederholt zu
verletzen, indem es Kampfflugzeuge und Bomber
weit über die so genannte Mittellinie schickte,
also jene Grenze, welche die Gewässer der Meerenge
von Taiwan zwischen den beiden Ländern trennt.
Wir sprechen hier von Dutzenden wenn nicht gar
hunderten von Fällen allein im Jahr 2020.
Nun könntest Du natürlich einwenden,
dass in den vergangenen 60 Jahren eigentlich
sämtliche Drohgebärden Chinas gegenüber Taiwans
eher als machohafte Angeberei zu werten waren.
Und ja, für die Vergangenheit hast Du damit Recht.
Denn obwohl die taiwanesische Armee viel kleiner
war als die Rot-Chinas, war sie traditionell viel
besser ausgerüstet. Technologisch, als auch
was die Ausbildung ihrer Soldaten anging,
Dazu kommt die Unterstützung der Vereinigten
Staaten, deren Flotte die Region kontrollierte.
In den letzten 15 Jahren hat sich das
alles jedoch grundlegend geändert.
Peking ist dabei, ein monumentales Programm zur
Modernisierung seiner Streitkräfte durchzuführen.
Um Dir mal eine Vorstellung davon zu geben: Die
chinesische Luftwaffe verfügt derzeit allein über
mehr Kampfflugzeuge der vierten Generation als die
taiwanesischen Luftwaffe an Flugzeugen insgesamt.
Die chinesische Marine stellt Flugzeugträger,
Zerstörer und Schiffe mit amphibischer
Transportkapazität in Dienst.
Die chinesische Armee hat mehr als 1.000
ballistische Kurzstreckenraketen stationiert,
die direkt auf Taiwan gerichtet sind,
führt kontinuierlich Manöver rund um
die Insel durch und verfügt sogar über
eine IT-Abteilung, deren Aufgabe es ist,
Cyberangriffe gegen strategische taiwanesische
Ziele auszuführen. Die gesamte Kommunikation
der Insel und all ihre wichtige Infrastruktur
soll bei Bedarf vollkommen eingefroren werden.
Zum ersten Mal scheint die Idee einer
chinesischen Invasion also nicht weit
hergeholt zu sein.
("Wir sind besorgt,
ob unsere Kommando- und Kontrollsysteme in
Kriegszeiten ungehindert funktionieren können,
ob das Land noch unter einem wirksamen Kommando
stehen könnte. Wang Ting-yu, Abgeordneter der
regierenden Demokratischen Fortschrittspartei
und Vorsitzender des Verteidigungsausschusses).
Aber natürlich... An diesem Punkt denken
wahrscheinlich viele von Euch... Aber,
Mark... Die USA haben sich doch verpflichtet,
Taiwan zur Seite zu stehen und es zu verteidigen!
Ja, das ist wahr, aber das Problem ist...
Wie weit würde diese Verpflichtung im Fall
der Fälle gehen? Und reicht sie alleine aus,
um die rote Flut vom Festland aufzuhalten?
Aufgepasst!
(STRATEGISCHE DOPPELDEUTIGKEIT)
Als die USA ihre offiziellen Beziehungen zur
Republik China - das heißt zu Taiwan - abbrachen,
um die Volksrepublik China
anzuerkennen... übrigens,
wir haben dieses ganze Durcheinander auf
VisualPolitik bereits in einem Video entflechtet,
Du kannst es Dir über den Link hinter
dem "i" oben rechts ansehen... also
damals verabschiedete der US-Kongress den Taiwan
Relations Act, ein Gesetz, in dem bekräftigt wird,
dass besondere Verpflichtungen gegenüber der Insel
aufrechterhalten werden, obwohl die taiwanesische
Regierung nicht mehr als legitime Vertreterin
des chinesischen Festlandes anerkannt wird,.
Um welche Art von Verpflichtungen geht es?
Nun, z.B. die Anerkennung jeder nicht-friedlichen
chinesischen Intervention als Bedrohung. Die USA
behalten sich in einem solchen Fall das Recht vor,
Taiwans Verteidigung zu übernehmen und ihm
alle dazu notwendigen Waffensysteme zur
Verfügung zur Verfügung zu stellen
- also eigentlich zu verkaufen.
Nun, Tatsache ist, dass von diesem
Moment an das in Gang gesetzt wurde,
was als die Politik der strategischen Ambiguität
- also Doppeldeutigkeit - bekannt wurde.
Das US-Gesetz sah zwar nicht ausdrücklich
vor, dass die Vereinigten Staaten im Falle
einer Aggression eingreifen würden,
behielt sich dies jedoch vor. Und ja,
diese zweideutige Strategie zahlte
sich über viele Jahrzehnte aus.
Einerseits konnte sich Peking nie sicher sein,
wie die Reaktion der USA ausfallen würde und
ob ein Angriff auf Taiwan nicht zu einem
direkten Krieg mit den Amis führen würde.
Andererseits bedeutete diese strategische
Zweideutigkeit, dass sich die Taiwanesen auch nie
ganz sicher sein konnten, wie weit die US-Hilfe
gehen würde. Sie hatten also keine andere Wahl,
als ihre eigene Verteidigungsfähigkeit
sicherzustellen und gleichzeitig ihre
Beziehungen zu China zu verbessern.
Und, liebe Zuschauer, die wir uns
wirklich stellen müssen, ist... wie stark würden
sich die USA *heute* tatsächlich engagieren?
Lasst uns dazu ein kleines
"Gedankenexperiment" wagen:
Wenn sich die US-Regierung in Zeiten, in der
sie Peking militärisch haushoch überlegen war,
schon nicht in der Lage sah, sich bedingungslos
hinter Taiwan zu stellen, warum sollte sie
plötzlich gegenüber einem China, das zur
Supermacht angeschwollen ist, klare Kante zeigen?
Dies ist keine unbedeutende Frage,
insbesondere nicht für die Taiwanesen.
Chinas wachsende militärische Macht ist nicht
nur zu einer Bedrohung für Taiwans faktische
Unabhängigkeit geworden, sondern erhöht
auch den Preis für die Beteiligung der USA.
Ein solcher Konflikt könnte ja durchaus sehr
schnell eskalieren, total aus dem Ruder laufen
und Auftakt des Dritten Weltkriegs werden.
("Wenn die Kugeln wirklich anfangen zu fliegen,
wird es für das amerikanische Volk, von
dem die meisten Taiwan nicht auf einer
Karte finden könnten, schwer sein zu
sagen: Nein, ich bin wirklich bereit,
Los Angeles gegen Taipeh einzutauschen". Michael
Hunzeker von der George-Mason-Universität)
Und nicht nur das. Die Vereinigten Staaten
sind geographisch im Nachteil. Wieso? Weil ihre
Verteidigungsfähigkeit in dieser Region allein
von ihrer Marine und einer Handvoll asiatischer
Stützpunkte abhängt, die sich auch noch bequem
in Reichweite chinesischer Raketen befinden.
Allein die Frage, ob die USA ihre dort vorhanden
Truppen schnell genug mobilisieren könnten,
um Taiwan überhaupt noch rechtzeitig
zu Hilfe zu kommen, ist strittig.
Und weißt Du was? Das Schlimmste ist,
das wir es hier mit einem ganz besonders
teuflischen Teufelskreis zu tun haben.
Denn die chinesische Regierung weiß
dies alles natürlich. Und ihr Verdacht,
dass die Reaktion der USA zu
gegebener Zeit nicht mehr als
ein formeller Protest sein würde - so
jetzt in Hongkong geschehen - motiviert
sie noch mehr, ihre militärischen
Invasionspläne in die Tat umzusetzen.
Mit anderen Worten: die Wirkung der Politik
der strategischen Zweideutigkeit hat sich
ins Fatale umgekehrt. Diese Doktrin
wirkt heute geradezu als Katalysator,
als Brandbeschleuniger, in diesem Konflikt.
Und genau aus diesem Grund fordern
viele Stimmen in Washington,
diese Politik ein für allemal zu beenden.
("Wir müssen klarstellen, wo wir stehen,
insbesondere indem wir alle verbleibenden
Unklarheiten darüber beseitigen, wie wir
auf die Anwendung von Gewalt reagieren würden,
und indem wir die Haltung und Struktur unserer
Streitkräfte ändern. - Elbridge
Colby, ehemaliger hoher Beamter
des Pentagon und Mitverfasser der nationalen
Verteidigungsstrategie der Trump-Administration)
Andererseits macht dies deutlich, dass
die Taiwanesen in der Lage sein müssen,
sich zumindest eine Zeit lang
zu verteidigen, bis Hilfe kommt.
Der zweite Knackpunkt ist also... Wie zum Teufel
verteidigt man sich als David auch nur einen
Tag lang gegen einen Goliath wie Rot-China?
Keine Angst... das verraten wir Dir jetzt!
(DIE VERTEIDIGUNG TAIWANS)
Nun, wenn man sich in Taiwans Lage
hineinversetzt, kommt man schnell auf
den Gedanken, es müsste einen irrsinnig großen
Verteidigungshaushalt haben. Militärausgaben
müssten oberste Priorität genießen, denn von
seiner Verteidigungsfähigkeit hängt ja unmittelbar
die komplette Existenz der Inselrepublik ab ab.
Tja, Du wirst überrascht sein! Die für 2021
geplanten Verteidigungsausgaben belaufen sich auf
nur etwa 15,4 Milliarden Dollar. Das sind nicht
mehr als 2,2 bis 2,4% des BIP.
(TAIWANs Progose der
Verteidigungsausgaben für 2021, etwa 15,4
Milliarden Dollar (2,2-2,4% des BIP))
Dies stellt zwar einen Anstieg von etwas
mehr als 10 Prozent gegenüber 2020 dar,
aber wenn wir die letzten 10 oder 20 Jahre
betrachten, stellen wir fest, dass der Anteil
der Militärausgaben während dieser Periode
gesunken ist. Sieh' Dir mal folgendes an!
Seltsam, nicht wahr? Aber warte nur ab!
Gleich wird Dir dieser Abwärtstrend ganz
und gar nicht mehr so seltsam vorkommen.
Trotz Einsparungen hat Taiwan in den letzten
Jahren weiterhin wichtige Rüstungsaufträge
mit US-Firmen abgeschlossen. Es geht um sehr
fortschrittliche Systeme wie z.B. erst im
letzten Jahr die Beschaffung von 108 Abrams
M1A2T-Panzern im Wert von 2 Milliarden
Dollar. Und diese stellen die absolute
Krönung amerikanischer Panzerbaukunst dar!
2019 schloss TAIWAN die Übernahme von 108
Abrams M1A2T-Panzern im Wert von 2 Milliarden
US-Dollar ab. Und im Jahr 2020 setzte Präsidentin
Tsai Ing-wen weitere 8 Milliarden Dollar in
Bewegung, um 66 F-16-Kampfflieger auf dem neuen
Stand der Technik zu beschaffen.)
Dies sind nur zwei Beispiele,
zu denen sich Raketen, Seeminen und eine Menge
weiterer Technologie und Gerätschaft aller Art
hinzugesellen. Insgesamt wurden allein in
den letzten zwei Jahren Zusagen über mehr
als 15 Milliarden Dollar gemacht. Außerdem
verfolgt Taiwan noch immer das F-35-Programm,
was weitere milliardenschwere
Investitionen nach sich ziehen wird.
Und das ist noch nicht alles.
Die taiwanesische Regierung
gibt ebenfalls Milliarden aus, um die
Rüstungsproduktion im eigenen Land anzukurbeln:
Hubschrauberträger, Zerstörer und ihre
ganz eigenen Kampfflugzeug-Modelle. Sie
entwickeln sogar ihre eigenen U-Boote, deren
Kosten sich auf über 1 Milliarde Dollar pro
Einheit belaufen. Das erste U-Boot
soll 2025 in Dienst gestellt werden.
Na, das alles klingt doch recht gut, nicht war?
Nein, ganz und gar nicht. Denn in Wahrheit ist
all dieser Rüstungsaufwand praktisch
vollkommen Sinn- und Zwecklos.
Warum? Nun, weil der Vorsprung Chinas
erstens einfach immer noch zu gewaltig
ist und zweitens auch noch immer
weiter wächst. Aber sieh' selbst!
Während China und Taiwan Ende der 1990er Jahre
praktisch dasselbe Militär-Budget hatten, ist
das Budget des chinesischen Riesen heute um den
Faktor 25 größer. Und das hat natürlich direkten
Einfluss auf die Kampfkraft beider Armeen.
Sieh' Dir mal an, wie das chinesische
Außenministerium selbst die für
2021 angekündigte Erhöhung des
taiwanesischen Militärbudgets bewertet hat:
("Egal, wie viel Sie ausgeben, wie wir alle
wissen, ist Taiwan eine kleine Insel. Wenn Sie
gegen das chinesische Festland kämpfen wollen,
ist es wie eine Ameise, die versucht, einen
Baum zu verschieben." Zhao Lijian, Sprecher des
chinesischen Außenministeriums).
Wie Du Dir an dieser Stelle sicher
schon vorstellen kannst, wäre das
wahrscheinlichste Szenario im Falle
eines chinesischen Angriffs - und dieser
Ansicht sind auch viele Experten - dass
in relativ kurzer Zeit erhebliche Teile der
taiwanesischen Luftwaffe, der größte Teil der
Seestreitkräfte und ein Großteil der wichtigsten
Infrastruktur der Vernichtung anheim fielen.
Und als ob das noch nicht genug wäre, kommen
auf Taiwan noch Probleme zu. Es sieht alles
danach aus, dass die taiwanesische Armee ein
Ausbildungsproblem hat. Erstens beteiligt sie
sich nicht an internationalen Missionen und
so haben taiwanesische Offiziere z.B. noch
nie schwere Waffen im Feld eingesetzt. Es fehlt
ihnen einfach die praktische Kampferfahrung.
Zweitens bereitet ihr der Mangel an
Soldaten weiteres Kopfzerbrechen.
Taiwan ist nicht gerade ein junges Land
und viele junge Menschen ziehen es vor,
ihr Leben anderen Aufgaben zu widmen als der
Landesverteidigung. Um Dir eine Vorstellung
vom Umfang dieser Problem zu geben: Zwischen
1993 und 2020 wurde die Truppenstärke der
taiwanesischen Streitkräfte deswegen um mehr
als 60% reduziert. Sie ist von 500.000 auf
weniger als 200.000 Soldaten gesunken.
(Zwischen 1993 und 2020 wurde die Zahl
der Soldaten in Taiwans Streitkräften
um mehr als 60% reduziert. Sie ist
von 500.000 auf weniger als
200.000 Soldaten gesunken)
Tja, das sieht wirklich gerade
berauschend aus, nicht wahr? Und
damit steht nun wie drückende Frage im Raum:
Wie um alles in der Welt könnte sich Taiwan
einer chinesischen Invasion auch
nur für kurze Zeit standhalten?
Diese Preisfrage versuchen auch allerlei
Militärstrategen zu beantworten. Und die meisten
Experten, sogar einschließlich des Pentagons,
geben Taiwan eine ganz eindeutige Empfehlung: Es
muss seine Militärstrategie vollständig umkehren.
Was Das heißt nun konkret?
Also: anstatt teure Militärausrüstung zu kaufen,
die im Ernstfall sowieso praktisch wertlos wäre,
muss Taiwan sich in erster Linie darauf
konzentrieren, die Invasion zu einer für
China so riskanten und verlustreichen Mission
zu machen, dass die dadurch verursachten
militärischen, aber vor allem politischen und
wirtschaftlichen Schäden für nicht tragbar wären.
Und die gute Nachricht ist: Taiwan verfügt über
einzigartige Möglichkeiten,
dies Strategie umzusetzen.
Als erstes muss es die Vorteile seiner
Geographie zu 100% zur Geltung bringen.
Wovon wir hier sprechen? Taiwan hat nur
14 Strände, die sich für eine Invasion
von See eignen würden. Der Rest der 1.200 km
langen Küstenlinie ist sehr gut durch Riffe,
Felsen, Klippen oder Betonpfeiler geschützt.
Und wenn Du jetzt denkst, diese 14
Strände müssten China doch reichlich
langen, um auf Taiwan Fuß zu fassen...
Nein, das ist durchaus nicht so einfach.
Wir sprechen hier nicht von Badeurlaub, sondern
von der größten Seelandung der Militärgeschichte.
Denn wie gesagt: China müsste sehr schnell
voranschreiten, um die Zeit bis zum Eintreffen
der US-Streitkräfte zu nutzen.
Du siehst also schon jetzt,
dass das wirklich nicht so einfach wäre.
Hinzu kommt, dass die ganze Insel sehr
bergig ist und jeder Quadratkilometer Flachland
sehr dicht urbanisiert ist oder mit Reisfeldern
bedeckt. Und das sind für einen großen Einsatz
einer klassischen, schnell voranschreitenden
Invasionsarmee mit Panzern, Artillerie und
mechanisierter Infanterie denkbar schlechte
Bedingungen. Denn in den Reisfeldern versinkt
das schwere Gerät und in den Städte ist zäher,
guerillaartiger Straßenkampf angesagt. Nix mit
Blitzkrieg! Taiwan könnte alle Vorteile einer
asymmetrischen Kriegsführung ausspielen, bei der
auch eine kleine Verteidigungsstreitmacht gegen
einen übergroßen Gegner durchaus Chancen hätte.
(Taiwan hat nur 14 Strände, die als geeignet für
eine Seelandung angesehen werden. Der Rest der
1.200 km langen Küstenlinie ist durch Riffe,
Felsen, Klippen oder Betonpfeiler geschützt)
Und, liebe Zuschauen, damit hätten wir den
Schlüssel zur Verteidigung Taiwans:
asymmetrische Kriegsführung.
Die wichtigsten Experten und
das Pentagon sind der Meinung,
dass Taiwan die folgenden Punkt angehen sollte:
Erstens den Bestand und die Kampfstärke seiner
Reservisten wieder auf Vordermann bringen.
Offiziell gibt es davon zwei Millionen, aber wenn
es hart auf hart kommt würde ihnen wohl die nötige
Ausbildung für die Guerillastrategie fehlen.
Zweitens eine radikale Umrüstung
hin zu mobilen Waffen, Seeminen,
günstigen aber agilen Systemen wie Drohnen -
Myriaden an Drohnen - kleinen Booten und autonomen
Unterwasserfahrzeugen - quasi U-Boot-Drohnen.
Außerdem - die perfidesten Waffen von allen:
Landminen. Wenn es um Haut und Haar geht,
darf's wohl auch etwas dreckiger zugehen.
Und ganz im Stile des Vietcong die schaffung
gewaltiger unterirdischer Operationsstrukturen
und Versorgungssysteme. Tief im Gebirge können
außerdem optimal Radaranlagen in Kombination
mit Raketenabschussbasen installiert werden,
sowie all die Drohnen- und Raketenfabriken,
die dort gut vor Angriffen auf der Luft
und erst Recht vom Boden geschützt wären.
Kurz gesagt: dem Feind muss jegliches
Vorankommen so zäh wie möglich bereitet werden,
er muss bis zur Unendlichkeit verlangsamt und
in eine Vielzahl chaotischer und verlustreicher
Reibereien verstrickt werden. Dies alles, um
durchhalten zu können, bis Verstärkung eintrifft,
und die Lage für die Chinesen dann so
schwierig wird, dass sie einen Erfolg
einer solchen Invasion für unmöglich halten
werden. Oder zumindest für das kommunistische
Regime so waghalsig und kostspielig, dass
dass sie nicht die Eier dazu hätten.
Und was Du Dir vergegenwärtigen musst:
wir sprechen von einer Strategie,
die eigentlich keine großen Ressourcen
erfordert. Sondern vor allem Entschlossenheit,
Geschlossenheit und ein wenig Gerissenheit.
Deswegen hat sich sich Präsidentin Tsai Ing-wen
jetzt offenbar entschieden, sie umzusetzen und
sich auf einen Guerillakrieg vorzubereiten.
Leider wird sie auch damit die Bedrohung
durch China nicht vollständig beenden
können. China könnte versuchen, die Insel
zu belagern, anstatt einzumarschieren,
es könnte eine Art Wirtschaftskrieg anstreben,
und es könnte sogar konkrete Sanktionen verhängen.
China wird nicht klein beigeben in seinem
Vorhaben, Taiwan das Leben schwer zu machen
und es sich irgendwann einzuverleiben. Die
Menschen auf der Insel werden also noch viele
Jahre mit all diesen Bedrängungen leben müssen,
sie werden immer auf der Hut bleiben müssen - aber
das alles ist besser als ein brutaler Krieg
mit einer unabsehbaren Zahl von Todesopfern,
auf den die bisherige - aus dem Ruder gelaufene -
Strategie der Doppeldeutigkeit klar hinsteuerte.
Die Fragen an Dich lauten nun also: Was
sollte die internationale Gemeinschaft tun,
um die Unabhängigkeit Taiwans zu
sichern? Untätig danebenstehen,
wie sie es mit Hongkong getan
hat, oder sich zur tatkräftigen
Unterstützung der Insel durchringen?
Und wie könnte diese konkret aussehen?
Wie immer bin ich auf Eure kompetenten
Kommentare schon hochgradig gespannt.
Wir hoffen, dass Dir dieses Video gefallen und
vielleicht auch etwas gebracht hat. Falls ja, gib
uns bitte auch einen Daumen hoch und unterstütze
uns, indem Du es mit Deinen Freunden teilst!
Und vergesst bitte nicht, dass wir jede Woche
neue Videos hochladen werden also verpasst
keines unserer Updates, abonniert unseren
Kanal und klickt auch auf das Klingel-Symbol,
um rechtzeitig benachrichtigt zu werden!
Mach’s gut und bis zum nächsten Mal!